well get ready to commute to and from
vegas by train we've told you about this
for some time but now brightline west
is soon going to break ground to build a
new 65 000 square foot terminal
it's going to be right on las vegas
boulevard between warm springs and blue
diamond
now these are some of the images from
the companies a similar project which is
in miami
the nevada california rail is going to
stretch from the greater las vegas area
there will be stations we are told in
victor valley also
in rancho cucamonga along with palmdale
the company says passengers can expect a
three-hour
ride from l.a to las vegas the
high-speed rail project promises to
bring economic and environmental
benefits with fully
electric zero emission trains
we'll be partnering with all the local
transit entities to make sure that we're
um being a part of their system but
moreover i think again the perfect
parallel to what we're doing here is
what we did in miami
where we really created we linked into
local rail we linked
into all of the you know
taxis limos so this project is expected
to generate about thirty thousand
construction jobs and a thousand
permanent jobs after it is complete
could take about three years before it's
finally finished